Our minds have made an error.
We look at these gliding beauties of marvelous
complexity and we think that they...and we...are
something of our own.
That life is a kind of indescribable magic…
Even Darwin said, in his gorgeous conclusion
to On the Origin of Species, that life was
something that had been “originally breathed
into a few forms or into one.”
This completely understandable perspective
is nonetheless an error.
There was no way for Darwin to know it...but
life….life is chemistry.
From diatom to Diana, life is not a magical imbued trait, it is a process of the physics
of our universe.
The precise and convoluted chemistry of life
requires specific physical and chemical situations.
And this planet has a dizzying variety of
such circumstances that, over millions or
even billions of years, living chemical systems
have evolved to thrive in.
But one thing that is always necessary is
energy.
A system without energy doesn’t just not
have life, it doesn’t have chemistry.
And so, the story of life is the story of
captured energy.
These are Oscillatoria a form of cyanobacteria
. Every second of every day, for billions
of years, the sun has been exploding, sending
energy to the earth in the form of sunlight.
And on the other end— or really, on our
end—are photosynthetic bacteria like these
that use the energy of that light to construct
chemical complexity.
These oscillatoria are gliding toward that
light so that they can harvest the energy
they need to produce a kind of chemical so
powerful...so important...that you will probably
be surprised to find out that it’s just
sugar.
Oh sugar, such a chemical marvel.
Just carbon and hydrogen and oxygen...but
an evolutionary innovation so fundamental
that it remains a primary source of nourishment
for even the most advanced living things.
You may have seen this beautiful filamentous
algae called Spirogyra floating on the surface
of water, where it also takes advantage of
sunlight to produce its own food.
Oscillatoria and Spirogyra are autotrophs...auto
for self...troph for nourishment.
In the world of ecology, we call these self-nourishers
the primary producers.
They are where it all begins.
Primary Producers can turn the fundamental,
inorganic components of their surrounding
environment into food.
In the case of photosynthetic (or, phototrophic)
organisms, the energy component of that surrounding
environment is light.
There are also physical components...they
need carbon dioxide and water and nitrogen
and phosphorous for building materials, but
light is the energy.
This is the first way organisms get food...they
make it.
And most autotrophs use light...but not all!
There also lithotrophs, for example, that
use chemical bonds in minerals to thrive.
Unfortunately, we don’t have any footage
of them...so just...more spirogyra for you!
And like plants in our macroscopic systems,
autotrophic microbes are the starting point
of the story of captured energy.
Because, in their bid to hold onto and use
that energy, they themselves become balls
of stored energy.
Not just in their energy storage systems like
their sugars, but their whole selves are bags
of entropically unstable complexity, ready
to fall into randomness the moment their chemistry
fails.
I think we have to understand here that randomness
is the natural state of the universe.
Not because of some inherent evil, but just
because there are literal trillions of random
ways for atoms and molecules to be scattered
about, and a vanishingly small number of ways
in which they will be organized.
And so, fighting randomness...that is the
cause of life, and that fight both requires
energy, but also, definitionally, stores energy.
Because an organized state tends toward disorganization,
the path down that hill is one that releases
energy.
And as that energy is released, it can be
captured.
And if it can be captured by another organism,
it can be exploited.
And so we have our second system living organisms
use to stay alive.
They don’t make their food...they eat it.
Single-celled eukaryotes, also called protozoans,
dine on autotrophs, digesting their organic
components to supplement their own bodies
with the nutrients and energy they need to
grow and survive.
And from there, nature weaves the complexity
of the food web, transferring nutrients and
energy through this network of organisms consuming
other organisms.
Protozoans eat protozoans, and sometimes even
a few metazoans— the microscopic multicellular
organisms like rotifers, water bears, or fat
flatworms.
And then you get to metazoans that eat protozoans,
like Daphnia, which in turn gets eaten by
fish, the microscopic now transitioning into
the macro.
These eaters consolidate the energy, not just
keeping themselves alive, but feeding the
more complex chemistry, pushing themselves
further and further from randomness...further
and further from the equilibrium state.
But in the end, no matter what, life neither
big nor small lasts.
Eventually, through random chance or wear
and tear, the chemical systems maintaining
this far-from-equilibrium state break, and
the living chemistry ends.
And so we have our final opportunity for energy
transfer.
The last link in the stored energy chain,
the decomposers.
As microbes and plants and animals alike die,
they decompose into the environment, their
bodies broken down and recycled by organisms
like this Peranema, which is usually found
among decaying organic matter.
Here, you can see its mouth, called the “rod
organ,” through which it takes in bits of
decomposing matter, and sometimes just other
organisms, and eats them, converting them
into carbohydrates that it stores in those
shiny paramylon grains.
Though these decomposers come at the end of
the food chain, well after the sunlight that
started it all, they are still surviving on
that stored energy originally flung out from
two atoms fusing in the core of the sun.
And, of course, the role they play in our
ecosystems is still vital.
As they break down once living organisms into
their chemical building blocks, they release
those nutrients back into the environment,
ensuring that those building blocks are available
to the autotrophs that will begin the cycle
all over again.
As we delve into more and more ecosystems,
the vast number of factors that have shaped
a microbe’s evolution become more and more
apparent.
But one thing remains consistent, the chain
of stored energy...the primary producers...the
eaters...and the decomposers, sustaining the
chemical system that keeps them complex...the
energy that holds them together, and that
is holding you together right now, preventing
you from simply falling into randomness.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
and thank you, also, to all of these wonderful people
for supporting this channel on Patreon and making it possible for us to do this.
If you want to see more from our Master of Microscopes, James Weiss
check out Jam and Germs on instagram.
And if you want to sign up to see more from Journey to the Microcosmos,
there's probably subscribe button nearby.
And you can always find us at YouTube.com/microcosmos